[Music]
[Music]
back at it again it's the fighter
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
in your 20s and now yeah I I skipped a
few grades because
I had a learning disability and for a
long time they thought that I was really
stupid but what they found out was I've
just um I'm just like regular stupid
uh
but I'm I'm 22. yeah I don't want to
have to talk about my age on here no we
don't have to talk make sure the cameras
are going so the thing is like ages you
can just clap Us in anything yeah yeah
you were talking about age and you are
said you're 22. yes 22 years old two
years old because I've known you I feel
like I've known
I've known you almost 10
I was 12. it doesn't matter I mean I
don't care like I don't care about that
[ __ ] like no but you're I'll be able to
rent a car when I need to when I knew
you you were six foot right six one and
now you're six three no I was always I
was six three since I met you like I had
bad posture that's what it was you're
you you kind of you you walked into the
room with an apology as my acting
teacher used to say you'd walk in with
an apology now you walk in with a [ __ ]
you right because that's what you're
acting your acting coach called it
he would watch you walk into the on this
in the scene he goes he'd go why are you
apologizing now does your acting coach
teach you how to be an MMA announcer
we'll be right back after where's my
camera
if you're looking for just the right
flooring you need choices and at
Marshall Carpet One you'll find
thousands of choices
including carpet
Hardwood
rugs
and luxury vinyl
so make the right choice and visit
Marshall Carpet One and rug gallery
and we promise with more than 50 years
as a family-owned business
we've got you covered
God
you're so Zen and we're back that was
Marshall rug Gallery very excited
you're uh I like your sweater man are we
are we going we're going we're always
going the the as soon as you walked in
live we started running live no you're
fine
you're fine
kicks too Ray thank you Rick Glassman
and you you're not committing to the
mustache but you I'll tell you okay yes
because there's an outline to it and I
and I and you either make up your mind
or or don't right yeah I made up my mind
because you look like you're in the
middle of the road yeah so so tell me
there's a um there's a uh an old saying
I think it was uh Heather Locklear that
said it's about the journey and not the
destination and if my destination is
that Flawless facial hair like Heather
then
sure you guys are right and I'm wrong
right but right uh uh Henry Cavill you
guys know who that is Superman yeah
wonderful actor English amazing Yeah
Yeah from the Isles so in the Mission
Impossible movies he has a great
mustache with a five o'clock shadow uh
ten o'clock shadow but there's no saying
for that
I want that but I when I find when you
trim your beard it looks like you
trimmed it yes the only way to really
get it is to grow it so what I have
found is get a mustache for six days
yeah start the five o'clock shadow over
and then like three or four more days
I'll have a couple of days yes I'm gonna
look like Henry Cavill no sweet your
arms are juicy he trains it's nice it's
cold he's built he's built to enforce
things right like Henry Cavill and yes
follow me up have you seen when he uh
reloads no oh could you pull up Henry
Cavill reloading where Tom Cruise has
him
is that yeah it's really cool can we
pull that up should we pull it up I
don't know if he punches that way but I
seriously no it's a Reload it's not a
punch
it's like you know some people will do
this yes
you're not you're not a bad athlete
you're rather coordinated oh my God yeah
yeah yeah yeah you you you're we'll cut
you a clip I rewatch white man can't
jump I believe they're remaking it
and they're doing jack Harlow let me
tell you something about this guy man I
watch him play he can't play or hey I'm
about to give a shout out to our boy
Rick Glassman yeah glass Glassman should
have gotten the part the Glassman can
hoop did he did he audition the audition
no no
my jump shot sucks
that's like
a million bucks I
know
ain't tall enough eat my butt you ain't
check the ball out eat my butt you shoot
from too far eat my butt but you make it
every time no [ __ ] I am phenomenal I got
big balls
I got a cool guy haircut I got take your
shoes off I'll send you this new post
isn't yours I'll send you the I'll send
you arm reload arm reload yeah watch
this he's a handsome guy he's a handsome
cat
oh
he was dead he just keeps doing it oh
that's his thing yeah you see that's the
mustache did you see that thing going
mustache beard yes yeah
no you think you can grow that thing of
a mustache you have good yeah I don't
want to go that much though I'm not I'm
I don't know why because again you're on
the fence right with your mustache well
no just right you've seen him he's he's
transitioning he's like a butterfly and
there's nothing wrong with that no not
at all no no I understand that so he's
are you saying that there's a problem
with with transitioning yeah what are
you saying Ryan where are you where are
you going with this no I was right what
you're saying I need to you're telling
me how I need a transition no I I was
expecting his when you [ __ ] your head
like that it makes me a little angry
because you please don't say [ __ ] to me
okay but well because you look like
you're trying to be an intellectual and
and and you're a little confident oh are
you mansplaining to me what I'm trying
to do Brian that's interesting you're
gonna tell me how to transition and now
you're going to mansplain to me I'm not
how to do it you attacked away first of
all you said to me and I hadn't seen you
in a long time you went you're funny and
you hit her funny why are you so into
terrible twice right here on my rib you
you went you're funny and you went like
that on my rib I just think it sucks how
insecure you are about your comedy
you've made me laugh and you don't have
to like be on and like insecure until
you came in and you did that yeah he
went you know what he did he went you're
funny like I had asked him if I was
funny sure or I was looking don't you
think Brian's funny of course
you guys think Brian's funny can we move
on let's leave some comments if you
think just say Brian you're funny
comments say Brian you're funny in the
comments come on Rick now did you uh
invoice Dalia for your performance at
his wedding what are you saying you were
you you were I heard you were very
Clinic thank you you were the the
centerpiece there's a lot of no that's
just because we were in the same table
there's a lot of funny people at a table
I'm sure I'm just you know I was doing
my thing it was my pleasure I didn't
give him a gift I think they have to
donate to charity and I know that they
wouldn't know if I donate to charity I'm
not gonna charity but I will be funny at
the dinner table stole the show why are
you doing that why are you doing that oh
sorry I just sometimes as an
intellectual and sometimes I now it
reminds me to be present you ever notice
that like to be grounded just feel where
you are like Heather Locklear says it's
about the journey yeah so I'm just like
feeling like feeling my fingers yeah
what was this smelling the air and now
are you reading a lot of books or just
meditation oh my gosh there's this book
I forgot who I don't burn this country
it's about um that's Witch Trials David
Rubin yes
um uh it's about Witch Trials and the
pastrami sandwich yeah I don't know if
that's true it's the reuben and uh no
it's actually Dave Rubin so I think
you're yeah the reuben sandwich and then
there's Dave Rubin yeah a friend of ours
friend of the shows maybe he read a
different book okay maybe
don't burn this country the art of witch
trials and the Reuben yeah that's the
reuben sandwich I think you're
misreading that we're not going to read
on the show right I can't read the whole
thing see your show yeah listen you guys
I'm happy I'm happy that you wanted me
here um we love you I think that this
show is you know out and uh and uh why
don't we get started hit the theme music
Rick uh you were a little cautious
during covet
and then and you've since backed off I
like your interview voice not Rick you
were a little cautious I want to put my
Invisalign sure that bums me out when he
does it why yeah I got four more trays
he's been doing for two years [ __ ] off
right speaking of four trays could we
pull up um Rick lessons I'm phenomenal
so you could see my jump shot thank you
oh yeah Rick can play Hoops you he looks
like a basketball player he looks like
an athlete yeah
well I'll send you some clips if you
said you you played tennis on a high
level or you played D two basketball I
wouldn't be surprised
just a basketball one yeah I don't think
um I'm phenomenal yeah I don't know if
if now is the time really to play it but
it might be we passed to see this okay
we missed it the top one it's right
there
somebody hit me with the fact that you
can legit freestyle rap
well
I mean one skill at a time here
I mean where we can just watch the whole
thing now I think that how long is it 15
minutes that's my get flagged the little
clip yeah it'll get flagged I'm sure
yeah why don't we uh skip a little bit
then okay
um you grew up playing basketball did
you play in high school
I don't wanna I don't need to talk about
my accolades okay Sports because I think
Rick Glassman has this great photo of
him playing against LeBron James in high
school which is just an insane thing now
I heard he's really good Rick's really
good if somebody told me that like he
was I think playing a pickup game with
someone like somebody in entertainment
and they're like hey man like you gotta
dial it back a little bit hit that Baldy
catch the [ __ ] ball dude you're not
aware of how other people
perceive you what are you talking about
good thank you idiot
whoops are you not entertained
[ __ ] nuts I am phenomenal I got big
balls
I got a cool guy haircut I got I love
that though okay guys
uh
if you want to learn a different
language I don't know if you guys know
this but I speak French
and that is because I uh well actually I
practice my French on an app that I have
on my phone right now it's called Babel
b-a-b-b-e-l I think and I've done a
bunch of language learning apps and
programs I think that Babel is by far
the best for a lot of reasons you can
listen to podcasts in the language you
can then have them translated you can
actually take live lessons you only 10
need 10 minutes to complete a lesson so
you can start having real life
conversations in a language in as little
as three weeks because believe it or not
it's not the way they set this up they
teach you the essentials first and
that's kind of how you do it they have
ai for lesson plans
um and they were created and so Babel
the Bible lessons were created by over
150 language experts there's a science
to it and voiced by real native speakers
not computers that's the other thing so
you get the accent you get the tone you
get the the tempo the teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective and with battle you can choose
from 14 different different languages
including French Spanish Italian and
German plus Babel Has speech recognition
technology which helps you improve your
pronunciation and accents that's very
important so you can uh you can listen
to podcasts like I said games videos
stories even live classes plus it comes
with a 20 day money back guarantee which
I promise you you will not need so start
learning a new language Journey today
Babble right now you get 55 off I wish I
knew this because I paid full price you
can get up to 55 off your subscription
when you go to
babblebabel.com spider that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-babel.com spider for up to
55 off your subscription Babble language
for life do not pay full price like I
did so our longest sponsor our longest
standing sponsor is on it
um I remember when Joe Rogan was
creating his own Alpha Brain he got
obsessed with nootropics I remember when
he would put the ingredients up on his
website I remember when he formed uh on
it and he was selling Alpha Brain uh
with Aubry Marcus and he would always
say if you don't like it you get your
all your money back you get a hundred
percent of your money back no questions
asked and that is still the case and I
remember when I was talking to Aubrey
Marcus when they were our first our
sponsor and I said what do you want us
to say about your company and Aubrey
said just be honest
just let the products that you use do
their own advertising do you believe in
it or do you not and one of the things
about on it that I love is I know the
kind of Science and care they put into
making sure that their supplements their
protein powders their amino acid
profiles whatever it is that they're
selling including their nootropic and
their Flagship Alpha Brain they make
sure that everything is the best it
possibly can be it's stuff that the
founders themselves use every day to
this day to my knowledge I've seen them
take it like before a podcast and
everything else so that's why I believe
in this company so much I think the
world of supplements is a very shady
world but on it has always been on the
up and up I trust them implicitly so go
to onit.com
f-a-t-k if you want the best uh
supplements on planet Earth I don't care
if it's protein powder I don't care if
it's mineral rules I don't care if it's
creatine but especially Alpha Brain
Alpha Brain is something they've done a
lot of research on it doesn't make you
jittery it's caffeine free
increases the alpha waves of your brain
helps with Focus memory cognition
um so save 10 on your order go to
audit.com
tfat or f-a-t-k-f-a-t-k
um and there it is I just want to talk
about a comedy
I want to talk about being woke I want
to talk about Kanye West let's talk
about all this stuff I want to talk
about you know uh what do you like about
woke culture what do you not like yes
like what do you think about what's
going on and like being a comedian now
is it harder now than ever after you
know what happened to Chris Rock
oh getting his head I don't think so no
his brother is Tony Rock being a better
comedian oh I don't know who's better
I'm just saying I don't know as I'm
saying like everyone has their own
realities uh comedy I think when it's
harder to make funny that's our job to
go harder our job is to say [ __ ] off and
here's the difference
you know I've been doing comedy since I
was 12. yes and one of the one of the
things that I've started to to like
really appreciate is our job uh our job
um as as people who have a voice to to
speak up against you know
ah
go on
no it's we got to give it long pauses
sometimes but I got what you're saying
you know what I mean pause and a lot of
times there's a lot of meaning in a
pause and people and you're one of those
people have always given a lot of
breathing room and a lot of power to the
pause and I want to I I think that comes
from your musicality because I got so
much from that pause
I filled in a lot of the space
and I'm getting lost in your eyes right
now so
and what's amazing is you don't blink I
watch the show
I've seen every episode and the
sincerity that you're offering right now
yeah Brian Brian it's Brian count Brian
yeah you told me is actually really
sweet and I think something that we
should lean into more on this show yeah
because seeing you like this you're
doing that thing with your hand again
though I just I'm trying to be here okay
seeing you like this is actually
attractive It's like because everyone at
least in the comedy world knows that if
you want if you want funny you get Brian
Callan he does the thing where he slaps
his quads and talks about horses and
pretends he's a bird yeah he's been
doing that for a while Rick and no it's
very funny I know but I do more than
that that sure that's a little bit
shitty okay do a dude let me hear a
minute of your stand up now yeah let's
see what you do yeah what do you guys
think there's nobody there Rick what do
you guys think you want us yeah Rick
this is
ladies and gentlemen it is my pleasure
to introduce one of the stars of one of
my favorite podcasts and never miss an
episode
fighter and the kid Brian Callan [ __ ]
all right fine hey guys I got a lot of
horse fantasies
this was up and I just [ __ ] he slides
in on his stomach I get on him and I and
he just takes me and I ride with no
hands right but that's that's the horse
of you said you have more than horse
stuff oh hit him with the pain I do
don't you don't you do something that's
not a horse joke do the penguin no I
can't remember the penguin um you want
something besides the horse thing
I mean what do you guys think
yeah everyone I want to be a Scotsman
and I want to ride up on my Steed I'm
having me
uh if if it's War you want it's War
you'll get if it's what you want it's
Warrior game it's not bad did you do it
nope not my thing if it's if it's War
you want it's War you're gonna get okay
relax your mouth relax your mouth if
it's worse you won't
[Music]
if it's War they want
it's War they'll get it's very scary
yeah very male Gibson that's right rats
I love you they were here before us have
you ever considered
um leading them I'm being serious by the
way leading a film and having somebody
write it because I don't think you would
and
um leading a film where you
um you're playing that kind of like
Scotsman roll yes
um the intention would be satirical and
ironic but like the tone of the movie
it's not a comedy like you treat it like
dead serious yeah the whole the whole
tone of the film and all the casting
your wig yes and playing it sincerely
yes because I think that where America
loses you is they don't get it
yeah you've been you've been
complimenting me but then you're cutting
my [ __ ] I got a question yeah both of
you answer this backwards
same do people get you
yes no I do well at comedy they laugh at
me no no you're fine don't worry I mean
you're funny right you're funny don't
worry about it I know that and you're
making me insecure now because you keep
saying you're funny like I'm questioning
it I think that your comedy is because
you're uncomfortable in sincerity you
don't know coming there and I think
you'd be a great dramatic actor thank
you I can do a lot of I mean don't don't
challenge me on that problem was it AP
Bio
was that your show no it wasn't what was
the show where you were a gym teacher
because you were very serious
no The Goldbergs the school yes he has a
spin-off school yeah I played you know
he is I'm a very I'm a good actor I mean
if you want me to do something dramatic
I can
maybe maybe give Rick a little taste
just so he sees your range of the
Italian now why didn't I play pro
basketball
you guys look at virtually identical
yeah oh that's fun to work with him was
he awesome wonderful guy Charles Barkley
for the audio only the best crushing it
Charles Barkley was he making you laugh
uh yes oh he's just great and also a pro
but also just guys like that who played
basketball and football have to have a
lot of social intelligence because
they're team players yeah and then
they're in the Limelight so they know
everything they've been there a
thousands of cameras yes do you feel as
a wrestler a solo sport is that why you
maybe lack those abilities no because I
came from football right did you yeah
are you a quarterback
um Thailand too big for quarterback Rick
and you know that so you're probably not
too big for quarterback what are you
talking about I think you are no no pull
up a picture of Donovan happily very few
no not these days I've sat next not very
thick but not a dominant mcnabb's bigger
than me no no but I sat next to the
government look at oh is he too big to
be a quarterback hit guy but but I'm
going to tell you this a very thick
version
Ben Roth russellsburg no that's a big
boy right Ben's a big boy Peyton Manning
huge football I there's nothing better
to me than Patrick's Sunday afternoon a
crack open a chorus oh a nice cold one
yeah I mean of course maybe a um a
Heineken and I sit back in my favorite
Lazy Boy and I just watch all the
different football games the Cowboys the
um they won
the Browns the Ravens
the uh Vikings yeah who's your team oh
dude any I love
um
all of them I just love the sport so
much did you watch the World Cup at all
oh my God I love sports yeah
I do too
I didn't get enough of the World Cup
if you could be I know if you could be
an athlete I'm an athlete you might I
know if you could be an athlete a
high-level athlete in one sport well I
am I am in basketball so I don't you
can't hoop I'll give him okay okay I
just don't care about the other ones
okay I'm but do you mind indulging me if
you could be the best soccer ask me
dramatically
Scottish dramatic if you could be a
great athlete I mean a crane breaking I
take it more seriously I like this would
it be soccer
football American football European
football you say football or Americans
they just say because you wouldn't say
European if you're in Scotland football
American food but also when you say
American football there should be a
little distaste because they would not
like it it could be football and also
when you say football make it like
football like talk about real football
what is beef start over
if you could be an athlete a great one
right at any spot would it be
football right yeah American football
tennis oh
sucker oh I said that God I said that
start over Dennis rugby start over but
be more disdain more disdain for
American folks throw him
War
what would you want to be the best at
football
American football musician yeah good
choice Premier League football good
choice yeah because yes because they're
the most they're the best looking yeah
um they have the the biggest the biggest
audience biggest the biggest which makes
the biggest money which makes the
biggest cake yeah correct uh and also um
you don't really it's not that uh you
don't get hurt it's the same yeah yeah
um and also you get to act like when you
get hit you get to do what everyone is
flopping yes acting yeah sure I think I
think football players proper football
soccer yeah they get a bad rap for all
the flopping because they call it
flopping but we don't understand is they
are at where as an athlete I'm an
entertainer right and I'm there to
entertain you yes I'm competitive and
yes I want to win and yes I do win
but I'm entertaining you and the reason
why we get paid as much as we do is
because people we I chose to get into
comedy can you not well I I had it I was
I had a 10-day contract with the cats
I'd attended contract with the Cavs
absolutely did okay never played but
practiced with them and got paid
technically I was paid as a professional
basketball I knew that good basketball
yes he's very good about basketball hold
on hold on stop everything the cabs paid
you to play basketball yes did you play
D1 ball I played I played basketball at
Kent State and you were very good let's
do one yes you played all four years I
played all four years
I didn't know any of this right yeah
well technically
I started a little late and it was
it was intramural but okay so it counts
so this I won I won no I know Rick and I
walked and I tried out and then and then
uh you know and then I I gotta because
uh for I practiced with a team at Kent
they they liked the way I how physical
and aggressive I was and they liked me
as a practice player and the coach went
over it was at Cleveland and had me come
with them and technically I said I want
a contract and see we give you a 10-day
contract and it was fifty thousand
dollars it wasn't very much money but
you made fifty thousand dollars to play
basketball as an NBA player
okay now insane where are you looking
what is that that's the truth um
and so that that hurt your eyes a little
bit didn't it the truth because we had
that truth meter and it comes with a
light right so what why are you looking
yeah there's another one so you try to
[ __ ] hide and we have how about that
stuff uh we're doing a show together at
the ice house and we're in the green
rooms like Derek all the comics and
stuff he's back there shout out to Derek
potson by the way will put his Instagram
handle up here Eric posted and Derek we
played basketball there at the time I
didn't know how good he was at
basketball yeah and you know we're
[ __ ] and I go you know I got a
basketball court and he goes yeah it's
outdoor though because you have the
money enough indoor courts well well
this was before covet though you
probably have the money for it now
you have nine podcast since then true
nine now I'm exhausted now you are you
look nice Bobby you look so exhausted
can I get a hard week your face is super
swollen like you look like you slept
three hours well I I had to take nights
okay okay you're funny and you see no
hey I'm not no I'm not I can secure
about it I know I took NyQuil last night
because I needed to sleep I haven't been
sleeping why haven't you been sleeping
do you think you work too hard yes
I work too much why do you do it do you
need the money stop won't stop I'm like
a shark if I stop moving I'll die you
know so you know uh sharks have a body
chemistry to regenerate themselves and
don't need the type of sleep that humans
need yeah that's what I heard well half
their brain sleeps the other half is
awake you know is it true that if you're
like a shark the only way to get you to
stop working is to punch you in the nose
yeah or turn me upside down but Rick
I I tried punching underwater and you
know I can punch you know in the air in
The Ether I can punch you you step to me
my hands are Viper quick and it's going
to be a problem here I don't think you
know I don't I really actually don't
think you know
I know I know a few my friends do but I
trained for eight years uh and I know
you're Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and I would
love those Chrome what the [ __ ] dude
come on wait what are you talking about
come here Rick Rick what the [ __ ] come
here for real Rick your hands are crazy
Rick Jesus Christ brick you're fast as
[ __ ] he's like crawl McGraw [ __ ] I can't
even come on no I'm huge first of all
okay
Jesus Christ you're working my body so
fast I couldn't even do anything
whatever you're gonna be condescending
because no I wasn't condescending but I
like the way you and then you went low
no would you like to get those hands on
Kanye West honestly I was being silly
before because everybody's talking about
I don't wanna it's I don't we don't need
to talk about a little crazy right okay
I don't talk about other people
I like that but you just struck me three
times you're my own show you're here I
know but you literally
be able to handle yourself because you
can so well thank you I know I panicked
a little bit because your hand Your your
long is big and you and you were doing
this and that was rather I've never I
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
so I I kind of and then you you went no
we saw it went here and it went low and
we saw it yeah but back to sharks the
problem is underground like I can hit
hard unless I'm fighting you but sharks
aren't underground no I mean underwater
I punch that hard
he's attacking your body but they don't
announce that they're coming you know
there's a song about this
um I don't know if you'll get flagged by
sitting in the right keys but
I want to go where the people are
I want to see I want to see them dancing
walking around on there what's it called
again feet hold for the hold properly
sorry you do what my mom does when you
pause for the song and she comes in
my properly train you got to learn pause
what are they called again
feet up where they walk up where they
run up I started a little high I can
still probably do it what were they
playing all day in the sun I Wanna Be
yellow pitchy there right yeah
bet you on the land they'd understand
that they can reprimand their daughters
bright young women sick of swimming
ready to head
not personally but he has a new special
on Netflix right now so you play
basketball you do comedy on a high level
and you can sing and you're six three
and you fight and he played for the Cavs
you just struck him you struck me both
of us oh I also speaking of strikes I'm
a very good bowler I could if I send you
some clips you're gonna put them in
thank you
Rick you just dropped him you know I
almost bought a perfect game
did you yeah 10 strikes in a row two
away see now boy was my arm tired for
real that's an eclipse
288. okay so I'm having trouble with all
of this right now hey hey don't you're
mocking him behind us back dude you're
being so disrespectful and childish
frankly can we just do a podcast dude I
don't know he's every time you turn your
back every he thinks it's funny to make
fun of you doing it right now
remember remember I risked my life and
came over you didn't risk your life
because I gave you proper we'll put up a
picture uh I gave you the proper proper
um protection what happened
well it was it was the week before we
went into lockdown but I knew it was
coming you did I had n95 masks for years
yeah you you you uh were we were all
afraid of it at first he no I did the
interview in the suit sweating my ass
you had to put a hazmat suit on yes
yeah and take my shoes off and then I
had to take the suit off outside did you
ever catch covet
I caught everything that was thrown at
me but unfortunately Kobe I mean
fortunately for that matter covert is
only throwing me one so far and you and
you caught it yeah
well that's why I didn't throw a punch
at you because I know you can catch my
[ __ ] come on throw punching me punch me
all right okay be cool
Jesus Christ Jesus like Christ dude he's
like stop I can't even see what the [ __ ]
you're doing dude you're like a giant
Izzy Jewish caught me here are these 60
frames a second can we slow that down
yeah slow that down all right slow I
literally I was I
that's nuts that you you knock my hand
down like that that quickly do you have
enough money between the two of you to
fund if I write uh a Scottish period
piece for him to be in a million dollars
honestly I know you know a million
dollars in a lot for a movie
but think about it you could put it on
YouTube
and people would love it would you
direct it I want to direct it and you
know I directed I Am phenomenal we'll uh
yeah I mean I love playing ball with the
comics have you ever played with Rick
Glassman no is he great Rick Glassman
Maybe
uh and I I say this in like in like I
haven't really seen him play a bunch but
he actually may be the best basketball
player we have in comedy but and this is
the thing about basketball he only knows
one speed and that is I'm going to
compete can I do that
whoopsies Urkel [ __ ] when you're on the
text chain like I'm gonna butt [ __ ] you
tonight when you say [ __ ] like that I'm
joking do you know that people don't
want to come to the game when they know
you're coming why doesn't anybody tell
me that
[Music]
I've never butt [ __ ] ever have you
yeah yeah it's great
I've done it a lot I am phenomenal I got
big balls
I got a cool guy haircut I got you also
have to have a little bit of
aggressiveness to be good at basketball
well you play will you play a character
in I'm not you know I'm not great at
voice I obviously do something like okay
you'll definitely coordinate the combat
stuff because I don't know you no you
know no no no are you sing in it yeah
yeah okay I mean I would do I'm in I
would help arrange the music I want it
to be good and that's not honestly like
I'm more Broadway but I think um and
also hip-hop but I think that you those
are two genres yeah very good no I know
dude but you're
man I feel like you're using this
platform to tell everybody how great you
are at a lot of different things and I
don't even have a [ __ ] fact Checker
so I'm late for the cat well but the
audience
no I know you can play basketball I will
say this your hands are just sing for us
his hands are stupid he didn't beat you
up his hands are stupid fast and I
realize right away that there's not a
goddamn thing right I'm not stupid I
have a learning disability and I just
think it's not that big of a deal and I
know your intention but it's worth
bringing it up because uh silence and
complexity is part of the problem okay
and uh I don't want to stigmatize people
who are seen as stupid or other just
because they don't fit in in a typical
place the way that you do with your
fighting and your podcast
so I'm not it's just so you know like
we're all great and some of us are
different and just relax yeah I got I
I'm a little bit Blown Away by how
expressive long and Powerful your
fingers are I'm a piano player too well
that's what I was going to ask you if
you don't play piano it's it's a sin are
we gonna are you gonna to ask me what
Clips you need or will I just have to
send it
I don't know how you do it I'll send you
some piano stuff
[Music]
do you still do your pot at your house
yeah
put your hand up against Brennan's right
now I think you have a bigger hand than
Brad those hands massive go ahead and
put your hand up there
nice I'll do the same maybe I should
date mine's a little thicker why don't
you do stuff like that you're funny man
I see I agree you're so [ __ ] insecure
yeah I got you on that you're insecure
no you're dumb what but you're so you're
like sometimes you make us laugh I think
it's just like don't worry don't don't
be bothered by missing a lot we could
edit your [ __ ] out I'm not dude this
isn't live I'm not
foreign
honestly dude it's so fun to do this
podcast I watch this every week every
time I turn on my computer yeah I'm like
first thing I gotta do we're in your
face what's what what are the fighter
and the kid talking about this week yes
and I'll listen you guys usually talk
about like the best stuff but like being
here yeah
it's different for real we're a metric
feels like you're on like back in the
day like Johnny Carson no it doesn't
feel like a high status thing oh like
but this is vintage old school [ __ ] bro
it no it just feels nice it feels nice
to play with the boys yeah Pioneers I
think you guys are some of the people
that do podcasts and it's so nice it's a
very generous now there is a lot of very
general podcast but one of The Originals
right so by original you mean like you
have been doing it maybe longer than
some of the other people not original as
in like your takes are original or
special no I mean still doing Undateable
no that show got canceled a long time I
don't know I don't follow
I don't know if you know this but I'm a
dramatic actor now I didn't
award-winning what yeah what did you do
uh if you want to pull up as we see it
Awards
bring that up please yeah I'm getting
mad
this guy's non-stop well he's
and I'm complaining I'm tired as we see
it was he in that oh yeah
for uh first on the call sheet my friend
I see her name there
where's your name
Spotlight there it is spot Spotlight
Award winner Rick Glassman what the [ __ ]
is going on you beat out uh Sue Ann no
no no no she another one of our co-stars
okay is that well let's I'm room for you
though you know no let's that's the
thing when we say it so sometimes when
we root for people we mistakenly think
that we're rooting against others and
the only competition I've ever known in
my life is of my former self that's
right there you go see you only compare
to yourself if I even do that because
I'm I I so appreciate and respect the
boy I was and the man I'm becoming I'm
only 22 so I have so much more to go yes
but like I I'm grateful for him and her
oh oh are you still with the same girl
I don't like to talk about that that's a
personal that's a personal question I
know we talked about on the show oh
um well we are no longer together but we
still haven't respect long distance to
get you yeah she's fantastic yeah you're
probably a great lover thank you
um just welcome you know that that uh
that song was for her I knew it
I want to go where the people are
I want to see I want to see them dancing
do you know any Disney that you see them
dancing yeah so what I do is I pull the
hand so Duncan you you're cutting it so
dancing
oh you want the runs well that's what I
do that's if I'm directing you I'm you
know that there's a song that uh a lot
of my fans
um know and love uh and it's and it's
similar to what we're speaking about
before it's about appreciating the
journey because sometimes as we're going
we hit these bumps or these uh these
these obstacles roadblocks yeah yeah uh
and there's a song
I would love if you guys don't mind do
you mind no I would love to hear I'm
gonna maybe make a couple pitch mistakes
here and there just so you guys don't
get flagged by YouTube we're fixing them
post and and I I don't bother people I
want to say one thing before you do this
yes look at me
go for it right of course no no well
well let's not let's not go halfway like
the mustache right let's let's let's go
full mustache don't don't explain to me
how I'm transitioning my facial hair
okay but is it fair to say go full
mustache here it's fair to ask it but I
don't need a man to tell me what to do
you also explained them earlier what
you're doing yeah yeah well he is a man
so I don't think he listened yes but I'm
trying to become oh yes but is that the
way you learn how to improvise
I'm trying to be more of a sensitive man
I'm having sex with my back with my
knees
cut to a clip cut to a clip we have that
clip chin yeah what will you listen to
the words for real because I've sung
this before to people and I think a lot
of people like oh Rick is just showing
off how good he is at singing again but
I'm like I'm telling you a story yeah no
I do a show there Griffin so he likes to
show off he can sing too oh Eric yeah he
has a beautiful he has a beautiful you
guys um got together and say yeah we we
love music we love each other Jake
Bandits big dick Bandits big dick
Bandits yeah so that would be that's
more something that I wrote yeah we
wrote we wrote together will you listen
to the words yes and then you could ask
me any questions about what stuff means
but let me finish then will you first
all over big dick maybe okay every long
long
stream
let me to where you are others who broke
your heart they were like Northern Stars
leading me on my way
into your love in our this much I know
is true
that God blessed the Broken Road that
led me straight to you
there's all these obstacles now I'm not
sure if you two have ever experienced
these but sometimes people have
obstacles in their lives and you think
oh but it brings you to where you need
to be so I'm gonna say this right now I
can't believe that girl broke up with
you and you can sing like that well she
didn't break up with me it was a it was
a uh Mutual well I don't even need to I
don't need to give any information but
the thing is
um
predominantly that's none of your
business
do you know what I'm saying well I'm
just saying I can't believe it didn't
work out and you can sing like exactly
but you're assuming it didn't work out
because I'm not skillful or have
unbelievable communication skills your
insecurities are coming out now now you
know like Brian you know I will
acknowledge they're absolutely you're
right there is some defensiveness I'm a
fan of you and I think I would like to
understand that I know what that is I
don't feel extremely comfortable
speaking on that kind of stuff
especially when she isn't here don't
bring up this girl yes and I'll tell you
this that's the best song I've ever
heard in person I said it
who else could sing
oh yeah that is right do you know that
song Can I hear you sing your version of
it he's a professional I I kind of wish
Rick would bring his voice down sure
maybe lock them doors and turn the
lights down low
get the music on the soft and slow there
you go baby
I've heard it only um
I like that yeah what do you because you
didn't say no so what's happening are
you gonna pull something up instead of
just doing it
no no no no I'm this isn't for them this
is for us and I'm part of us I want to
see it I'm trying to think do you have
something beautiful like something
beautiful
a ballad
I can't kiss from a rose
I've never seen seal stuff oh I knew
that about you she was bad skin no
because he told me that believe that
that's what he said back in the day
what's something beautiful you could say
I could try to think some and then get
back to you I can't even think on the
spider with a song okay well
go like this do this
and then it's gonna make you think of
something
National national anthem
doesn't matter make him up
oh say again you see I'm just gonna
laugh the entire time well he does uh he
likes he loves Tim McGraw I do love
country though yeah maybe lock them
doors down low
put some music on that's soft and slow
baby we ain't got no place to go
I hope you understand it's a music
it's a musical fighter have you ever
done a musical episode I have on this
show well we've done that we've had some
singing We had a Caribbean tiger back in
the day big dick it did it with Will
Sasso we had some songs for a while we
all tried singing Silent Night one time
that was that's very difficult the
silent night if you take it seriously
how does that song Start I I can't do it
but I could probably do it
silent night
since you're taking it seriously yeah
it's him yes but take it seriously I
can't sing
okay be serious now and don't know no
laughing well you can sing bring up the
bring up the uh I don't know the lyrics
The Silent Night uh bring up an
instrumental will you type in
royalty-free Silent Night instrumental
royalty free Silent Night
okay but instrumental does that means we
can play it
you know way around YouTube
man I'm phenomenal what an amazing it's
also it's like really cool and funny
your gift
instrumental all right free
non-copyright song yeah there it is
right there all right the second one
down one one more down
uh down says royalty for you but let's
still credit uh thanks music by Pedro
for this gift okay ready always credit
always
oh
[ __ ] it's so hot nah so you can bring it
down an octave you don't have to oh
bring it down and bring it up
oh can I see that yeah we bring up the
words too yeah and go I can I'm going to
get it I'm gonna go back first I'm Gonna
Cancel up the lyrics yeah I'm gonna
bring okay my voice is going to be
beautiful hold on let me just did you
take singing lessons Rick I taught him
but no man you're really making me mad
dude I gotta be honest no no I'm I'm a
piano player and I have a relatively
Perfect Pitch so I'm able to sing fine
but my I'm not a singer sure you know I
could do scratch yeah I'm gonna sing I'm
gonna sing the first
stands go ready let's get the legs
thank you
oh is this distance
we're coming in on all is bright all
right try it again try again right yeah
start over start over start over yeah
yeah
all right ready hold on well are you
ready
[Music]
I don't want Christmas shut up shut up
[Music]
sleep in
Heavenly peace
all right you're doing the next verse
[Music]
I don't want Christmas anymore
[Music]
[Music]
you're my coach you're my coach
ES
[Music]
exclamation point now this one is softer
will you show us we do the next verse
please Jesus
[Music]
in the back of the room
pure
lights
red radio
oh my god dude you can't do that he's
not cats
let me show you how to do it start from
the beginning
it's a short song you're definitely not
going to sing the whole thing but we're
gonna listen you sing the first stanza
I'm gonna do the whole thing or I'll
leave it there you go I was just a
little mermaid
[Music]
[Music]
I always think of chicken tenders with a
mild sauce
that's enough but you see what I mean
God damn it that was don't say that
especially on this song No I know I
apologize that was so good are you
crying I'm crying did I do that it's so
good God that was good it's amazing how
like you don't have to believe in any
particular secular religion to
understand that there is a higher power
even if it's just the universe's energy
Life Force and and when we're able to
tap into the spirituality of
understanding that we are both important
and significant while at the same time
insignificant by relativity of no more
important than the other person
[ __ ] you're saying nothing dude like
listen bro favorite singer oh uh You're
gonna laugh at me I'm not gonna say it I
want to know Ray Charles that's not bad
that's not a bad that's great why would
I laugh at that I'm not gonna argue with
that well you told me that you don't
really
I don't care for I don't know what the
word is a black musician I have never
said that you said oh you said that's
not like your preference what's your
favorite musician you're spreading watch
this first favorite three musicians
[ __ ] my favorite few yeah three yeah
Bono Elvis and the white guy yeah see
their whole life I didn't mean that I
meant Springsteen I meant Springsteen
[ __ ] dude see you're funny man you just
need somebody to tee you up you know
what you need you don't know how to
write like if somebody sets you up you
know how to you have a funny energy dude
I think you're funny I I have a horse
Spanish
you know I'm gonna be honest I came in
here I'm having coffee I'm having fun
you guys are a couple of alpha males and
I'm like leaning in and I'm playing in
that competitive Vibe but I just want to
take a second to be serious and say this
is so nice and I'm having a nice time
and I don't do other people's podcasts
too much I always do mine and your
podcast is called what it's called take
your shoes off can I do your podcast
you know wow I sent you both messages uh
back in 2019. yeah you came on
um you uh you told me um you know yeah
uh get back to me or I'm busy or
whatever no um and now that my podcast
is now one of the it's the biggest one
of the biggest number one comedians
take their shoes off than Rogan no in
Los Angeles oh gotcha that that is
guests that doesn't also have look out
of all the comedy podcasts in Los
Angeles that is a guest podcast not like
us driven guest driven that um uh not
including people that have podcasts that
are guest-driven but also another
podcast that is like the same team
mine's the biggest
okay and now you're like oh I want to do
your podcast Malcolm you couldn't do it
then I was busy probably doing stuff I
take I have family I have oh you don't
have a family anymore I have my fighting
I have stuff I have a family too oh yeah
I made it and also a whole bunch of
podcasts yeah and you had to come over
here to put on the Hazmat suit you were
very respectful I don't even remember
you offering to come on yo let's pull up
your DMs I don't think you had a podcast
pull up your DMs no no well my so I had
to change my account you want me to pull
them up
I'll tell you what he big timed you do
do a minute of stand up for real without
any horses okay and make both of us
laugh and you could come on
goodbye in ten one shot minutes okay so
set a timer we'll do it in 10 minutes
it's 10 minutes okay Jim can we set a
timer for 10 minutes
okay Sierra will you set a timer for 10
minutes and I appreciate and respect you
a series of women and then it's nice to
let them know I didn't change the voice
though why
you're saying if you wanna I don't mind
a woman telling me Rick I just realized
I know very little about your background
where'd you grow up oh smart yeah
interviewing me showing me that you're a
pro yeah I grew up in Cleveland
I'm sorry about the Browns huh well
although we almost had Baker Mayfield on
the fight companion and you know Baker
was was drafted first round by the
Cleveland Browns now they went zero and
16 I believe no that's a tough one no
they did but he was I think in 2016. no
before him 16 team yeah okay
um would you pull up would you YouTube
search
um uh Grandma Glassman Browns
oh man you make you keep doing that with
your fingers dude and I find it you know
his Bob's owns the top rug store and we
already threw a commercial in your dad
does his dad does not mine your father
your father's ruggedeer in in Cleveland
all the rugs in the thick boy so your
dad's the rugs are of Cleveland
so you grew up with all that I don't
know enough about the the history and
the origins of the words are and I don't
want to appropriate that term uh but
maybe this is your grandma Yeah here um
my grandma uh is a huge Browns fan and
gets very angry at my Uncle by the way
here where you click that she takes care
of herself oh her face she's 114. I
don't know if I can watch the whole game
oh [ __ ] he almost got it an
almost an interception oh now they have
to run the ball up the middle for two
years shut up Robert
this is going to be a long day for me no
we could press pause we don't need to
watch much more but she is a [ __ ]
Spitfire yeah I'd love to get her on
your pod and she says I'd love it she
she says what's that the booker DMV oh
are you does my grandma need to have a
super successful podcast before you
would uh work with her
unreal that's not at all what it was our
Booker Tom McCormick said
I said get look get him on well now not
now now that I've won awards for a
dramatic actor and well I didn't know I
saw my third TV show out on ABC in
February and I know that I'm killing it
wait a podcast you're gonna be on a TV
show on ABC
yeah yeah okay I was on two shows on ABC
yeah that's something about that yeah
now that you're not on them anymore now
you want to bring me on and try to milk
milk
not a big deal look at you this is it
yeah you want to watch our trailer oh my
God
yeah I do actually so you won't be able
to because it's got music it's kind of
exciting
is this a dramatic show oh yeah it's
very dramatic very serious oh dude look
at you look how serious I am I was 21
when we filmed it you look like you're
21 there I played 25. what do you who do
you play there who are you in this in
this this it's uh it's
no not yet you have uh another certain
amount of time okay
um it's about uh uh three young adults
on the autism spectrum looking to find
Independence relationships and
friendships
together while living independently
well
great sounds amazing
what's going on with your eyes you're
not you're not feeling it no I mean it
sounds good I want to watch that
okay well let's pull up the pilot
okay beautiful show if you want I mean a
lot of times like if you if you type in
as we see it Rotten Tomatoes you'll see
like you know a lot of times these
serious shows get critical Acclaim but
the audience score isn't good isn't that
annoying yeah I think I have a theory on
all this [ __ ] on the our audience
exciting all of us for all of us I think
all of us in in this business whether
you do a TV show or whatever wait a
minute the audience the Run oh my God
that's incredible I see what you did
it's fresh at 90 but the audience score
is even higher for a serious dramatic
show you normally don't see stuff like
that 97 audience and 90.
you look like your fake surprise and I
feel like you've already looked that up
and you set that up because I don't
believe that your surprise is real
no I was doing comedy surprise
but very grounded serious it's pretty
impressive yeah now my question is do
people a lot of people continue without
disabling so people could see don't
watch stuff like this a lot of people on
what well I just feel like we're living
in a time where everybody look at that
has no attention span and it's worse
than ever because of ah
[Laughter]
that's why you got to do that but that
was almost
people say that b but they're you know
like that Dahmer series which is an
eight part series long over a billion
views well murder the Wednesday show
Wednesday I'm watching Wednesday now I'm
ready what is it
is it really Tim Burton Tim Burton
directed it you know what's interesting
what's interesting about it it I think
it's doing so well you know she in the
first 10 days of it coming out get 10
million Instagram followers new ones
from it and I think it connects with so
many people because it's Tim Burton it's
dark it's an IP that we recognize and
love Yeah but also it's kind of like a
young Nancy Drew mystery it also appears
appeals to the younger demographic and
it's great to have television that your
whole family could sit in and not like
oh I'll watch this with my kids or oh my
kids are allowed to watch us with the
adults but just good at home fun I
haven't seen a show like this since as
we see it out on Amazon Prime right now
fantastic show and it's interesting
because it's so great being able to be
educated while being entertained I would
argue being entertained first but we all
we are learning about
we are learning about something that I
think is important and and and uh wait
hold on hold on what is important
because I feel like you're being super
General again and that whole thing was a
[ __ ] plug for your show what is
important oh yeah I don't mean to to
dance around anything absolutely I'm
plugging the show I'm so proud of it
it's important to understand you see a
lot of shows and movies about autism
they kind of are on one end of the
spectrum they're either so unable and
they need all these help with all these
obstacles or there's these savants that
are good at counting toothpicks or
they're amazing doctors and the reality
is there's a lot more in between of just
we're all people a lot of people say
this is an Autism show but it's really
just a show and some of the characters
of autism anybody could relate to
difficulties in relationships talking to
girls or boys or theys or thems or hers
or she's or whatever
now do the kids on that show actually
have autism yes
well okay you don't have to be this
sincere we get it don't whisper yes like
I it's not a moment of silence okay
you're not that Noble for being on the
show you got cats oh no I'm blessed to
be able to be a small part in telling
somebody's story and if I didn't do it
somebody else would but it's not about
me being in it and being great winning
Awards what it's about is the show being
important and most importantly and I
hate to say it it's superficial it's
downright entertaining You're gonna
laugh you're gonna cry you're gonna feel
you're gonna feel good after oh you
don't want to feel good you don't have
to watch it [ __ ] Rick everybody wants
to feel good I mean 97 of them sure
turning this into a hole have you seen
have you seen love on the Spectrum oh
love so good
you guys this is so fun I hope I'm not
coming across too aggressive because no
God no because I really look up to look
up to um
you know Brandon well
you know like I just look up sometimes
and I see like the studio that you have
and I'm like wow you guys are doing well
yeah yeah because nobody no few people
gold plate their ceilings
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] dude
[Music]
show Alpha dude you just [ __ ] smack
the [ __ ] out of me on my own show so
it's so inappropriate that's so
inappropriate that you just smack the
[ __ ] out of anything like you
mansplaining to me you hit me you hit me
three times on my own show that's I
landed more than three yeah no [ __ ]
you just hit me in the stomach and the
face and it's a good thing I know how to
cover up and make myself smaller and
keep my eyes open you know what if
there's something you're good at it's
it's it's it's hiding and making
yourself look small well no I know how
to roll
them all drinking shots no I'm not as
tall as you are but that's right
insecure small steamer bone yep
complains about his bones
that was a [ __ ] dude you just
attacked me yeah you did I I it's my
timer yeah we got another minute 30.
Rick you know what you do when you come
up you you went you do this you hunched
over and then you went yeah well I gave
you a smaller Target
is that what it was yeah because I had
no openings you know I'm a uh you know
I'm a fencer well I'm not a fencer now
but I used to fence all the time and and
um
I got into fencing because I asked so
many questions I was always confused why
are the hands behind their background
why are they not facing the way where
they could jab the fastest and and being
to the side makes you the smallest yes
and that's why I got into fighting
because I learned and you know a lot of
a lot of people they will have their jab
hand be their weaker hand yes
um I I was young and I got very
defensive when I first started training
and I didn't like anybody referring to
thinking I have a weak hand this is why
I'm so good I could drive left just as
strong as right yes so I actually
learned to fight wrong and I would lead
with my right and it actually made my
left stronger can I show you yeah please
do
so [ __ ] here we go again okay now what
are you gonna leave your glasses on for
this one well he hasn't been able I
can't there's no openings
now Rick I'll tell you what I'm happy
this is for real I'm very happy we don't
live in a time when men settled their
disputes oh my gosh with swords I do
because swords are unforgiving
I it's interestingly enough feel like a
sword is one of the more forgiving oh my
God because because with sword fighting
and not the weapon itself but in proper
melee combat there is uh an honor there
is there is there is a sport respect and
melee combat a proper melee with sword
uh oh I'll tell you more about it after
you make Brennan and I laugh with yep
I'm gonna stand up
um all right cracking the cold one uh
let's see online are you sober I'm not
sober but I don't really drink I find uh
drinking um messes with my faculties and
I shine the brightest when I allow
myself to be the most true to who I am
uh we're gonna start a stopwatch uh
ladies and gentlemen Brian hey Brian
yeah I know you want to sing seriously
but you joke around here's your time to
really get on the take your shoes off
podcast which by the way have you seen
the editing on it I mean the visuals it
is fantastic it's a beautiful
time I mean why is it that you want to
go on it so much and it seems so much
it's popular right it's just I wanna I
wanna up my profile a little bit well I
still take us on the road here's your
chance oh wow and
seven we're gonna be quiet on two five
you could keep doing it four
three
hey how we doing out there everybody
um hey how come we don't see can you
imagine if
animals were celebrities
uh this is Arnold Schwarzenegger as a
bunny rabbit yes I like this
carrots
and cattles I'm I live in the whole uh I
have to eat carrots oh dog I'm happy to
hop I have to go into my whole street
Christopher Walken uh I'm glad you
brought up Christopher Walken this is
Christopher Walken as a pigeon this is
Christopher Walken has a pigeon
cool
cool
bread
on my mind
sourdough
give me some bread or I'll fly up and
pack your eye you [ __ ] sucker
hey a small bird tiny skinny legs big
chests cool one all right and it's wrong
so I because I didn't have as much time
we'll go to current events
so is he not making a show
um
that was literally I didn't know I'll
have time to him hey I got you I've been
the best look at your schedule
he's booked through the I don't like
when people do that to me you know when
I was first starting out a lot is for
you A lot of people would give me the
runaround like Brian yeah and they would
say yes but no follow-through yeah and I
never had a problem with people saying
no to me it's it's no and just tell me
the truth I'm not I'm not big enough I'm
not cool enough I'm not hot enough I
haven't won any drama awards yet but
like at least now I know yeah but I I so
out of respect when people say can I
come on your podcast or do you want to
come on mine if I don't want to I'll be
honest yeah so so Brian so ask him right
now
be honest completely honest I know but
do it be and tell me also tell me why
tell me why you why why my podcast who
cares it's just another [ __ ] podcast
or is there something fun about mine
that you want to really go and dance and
play it just looks like I'd love to come
on your podcast because it would give us
a chance to spend time together ask him
a little small detail about your show
tell me something about my podcast that
you like maybe when he does this
what happened well so first of all I
love that podcast because a lot of it
it's just it's fast-paced bad podcast
what's it called take your shoes off
it's fast paced and it's funny as [ __ ]
and it's like unpredictable and you
never know what's going to come ah [ __ ]
see that that's an example of that yeah
I'll be on I gotta figure it out
because I want to put you like I I don't
want to have you I want to find a time
where like I don't have advertisers does
that make sense yeah you want to slot me
in and feel like we're like an episode
like a week that I could have taken off
do you feel it there's not going to be
big numbers or something
um honestly God damn it I don't know I I
wouldn't be surprised like if if I'm
really funny and people are sharing it
but
yeah I'll have you on is it really don't
even worry about it I think you're funny
maybe some time you give us some space
between this you want to come on over
right after this and do it today is the
only time in the next few months I have
time could you do it today today though
because I have you want to do it one of
my three kids I have to I thought you
wanted to do it I do want to do it if
you could come over today I'm in I'm in
I'm in the Valley come over today we'll
do it what time right after this I have
my Kung Fu class
okay well you could fight you could
fight you could fight for your uh for
your youth um holding on to it for that
matter or you could fight for uh your
play your career and yeah your career
you're [ __ ] being insulting right now
dude everybody who has been on my show
in the past two years
is now working
right hand I like the right hand
is it because of me
I honestly to think so I mean the
exposure must be crazy
well the people that watch my podcast
are I will say this about my goblins
they're
they get it you should come on our
pocket you're already on it never mind
you know what you should do my podcast
I'll come over today let's go to current
events hit it chin
oh Victor boot yeah well it's starting
off with this but you guys know about
the trade Brittany Greiner yes for this
guy yeah Victor bout let's not let's
bleep his name and not say his name to
not that's why he that's why that's what
he wants they want he wants us to say
his name that's why he did all this
stuff with the arms he's a big fella
he's a big fellow fellow and he looks
like a quarterback spent a lot of time
not the best trade but at least we got
American out of this is that him right
now
doesn't look bad 55 years old doesn't
look bad
mm-hmm well now repeat the a lot of
Americans were upset because they
thought how could we not get that
veteran out of there too who's been in
there I think for four years yeah
serving a 25-year sentence in Russia yep
they tried to get him first now that's
what the White House says to take you
with a grain of salt so they said we try
to get them and restaurants are
absolutely not they're like give us I
forget who they want some big profile
guy and we wouldn't do it so he's off
the table right so it's Brittany for
this Merchant of arms death arms or
whatever you said it right thank you
merchandise yeah he supplied weapons in
Congo Liberia Sierra Leone if you know
anything about that it was the worst
[ __ ] uh conflict they did the worst
things you can imagine uh child soldiers
all kinds of [ __ ] and he supplied both
sides like we know this not a great guy
looking Downer yeah brought the mood
down didn't it sometimes sometimes
sometimes sometimes in front of me man
I'm a very intense guy I like his
mustache and you should grow a mustache
like that and I don't know why you won't
it's amazing to me yeah well uh uh you
know I'll send you a picture of me with
a with a mustache I get we'll put it up
I mean that's a good mustache do you
mark that remind me what assets you need
grow a Victor boot mustache
now does he just go back to work yes
he's going back to Russia Putin and he
are very close and he's going to be
living the life of Riley
now does this encourage Russians to
steal more Americans that's the problem
the problem is if you start making it uh
profitable to take hostages that's what
the cartel does that's what happens so
you got one of us okay we'll just kidnap
one of yours now they're going to learn
the hard way if they they get the right
WNBA player you steal someone else less
famous probably not going to trade
probably getting the trade that's true
so if they took Brian no trade isn't
that interesting they wouldn't if they
took you you think that they don't want
more fighter in the kid I think that you
think if if they took you or they took
um Rogan
he would probably eat his way out he
wouldn't even need America I would say
that they depend
ation if it was a very
they would keep they would keep uh uh
Rogan in jail now what was that slip of
Boudin who is buddhan
because that means something to you that
confused me as well yeah well I was
thinking about it Victor Boot and I was
thinking about Biden and there's a lot
of there's not to get conspiratorial but
there's a lot of chatter that they might
be the same person six syllables
now you're saying if my if if today's
world binds you know I think if Joe
Rogan
it's a good chance
he's out if he went to jail in Russia
what do you think it would be that would
they would have gotten him for weed
100
. it just goes to show you you shouldn't
we shouldn't be um don't go to Russia
yeah we're doing weed over there well
don't bring drugs to another country you
know it's tough when you're when
anything drugs swearing
um showing your face having sex with
somebody who you're not married to like
there are these things that we do that
we don't think about us doing anything
yes and then you go to another culture
and that's not what they do there and
it's scary and it just goes to show you
how much research you need to do for
example when you want to do something
you want to go somewhere you do research
right yeah you agree yes so tell me what
you like about my podcast
uh I I think it's fast-paced it's
unpredictable tell me give me an example
give me an example of something you've
seen there's so much of where you're
like you'll be like you know you'll come
up with a topic and then you [ __ ]
boom and you can be true or false has he
had Mark Barron on of course he's had
mark on his pocket no true or false
the world's [ __ ]
but the problem isn't new man
[ __ ] man for real social media isn't
[ __ ] everybody up you know what's
[ __ ] everybody up [ __ ] access we
weren't built for all this information
we can't really even understand it and
oh oh I'm addicted to cocaine or for
heroin so I have a problem but this this
is harmless
[ __ ] I agree it's not harmless
that's why I don't even have a phone I
agree this is just for work and pleasure
it's a problem so what's important to
know is
where am I giving myself away
right and when we recognize that we are
flawed we understand that oh there is
something we could do we could do this
we could connect and you're not you're
and you're not saying anything dude you
liked it he's making me mad you know how
much more generals mustache has five
more days [ __ ] chin get me to the
next [ __ ] current event before I
drown in generalities
besides I do think that I do think that
we have the rise of the new Puritans and
at the end of the day none of us can
really do much uh I'd love to I'd love
oh look at is that a Jewish woman I like
seeing that on Google that's a very
Jewish woman isn't it it is a I don't
know oh there you go Hungarian American
biophysics 100 Jewish guaranteed
she guarantee she's Jewish look it up
lived in 95.
I say that because she's from Hungary
she's a physicist
she's a woman you know especially back
then but even if you weren't Jewish if
you were Eastern European there was
there was some there was a lot of
similarities yes
if she's not Jewish I'll be very
surprised if she's due in that Jewish
you you can't come on my podcast if
she's Jewish you can oh what deal yeah
I'm Jewish I mean I could be doesn't say
anything about Jewish good I don't think
we needed to find people by their sexual
orientation or religion anymore Brian
did that I agree I'm a Centrist dude I'm
neither a man or a woman I'm right in
the middle
um this one right here
if it loads basically a sheepdog
was able to kill oh I saw this no I have
been keeping up on this I like this one
and then it ran into the woods to hide
yeah or to heal yeah and you know what
actually could I take a second or maybe
even a few minutes yes 10-15 minutes the
difference between hiding and healing is
all based on the perception this is one
of the few things that reality is based
on the perception of the outsider
because we hiding and healing aren't
mutually exclusive but if you look at
this dog that saves this family and was
attacked by all these coyotes and then
it goes into the woods because it's hurt
and it comes back we're like oh it
needed its time to heal but if it ran
away without saving them and got hurt a
little bit we would say oh what a little
[ __ ] and it's judgment and the truth is
we need to recognize that everybody has
their own needs their own time read the
thing killed 11 of the hold on it killed
okay
eight of the eleven that's [ __ ] all
these are getting pretty frisky man dude
he killed
yeah I mean I'm in one sitting so with
ninja training we used to have to right
um we used to have to sneak up on them
with throwing stars and the most I ever
killed and I know I'm gonna get a lot of
[ __ ] for this but
111.
it's on record anybody you snuck up on
them they weren't doing anything wrong
so one of the things with ninja training
is you have to build a walk without
breaking a twig under your feet and even
on even on Dead Leaves and so even on
Dead Leaves so my master
um used to always make usaki
did you work with the irukasaki how did
you know I
I trained with Europe that's why your
hands are
that's why I was training that's why I
betrayed hey do we have do we have a
quarter I want to show you guys how
quick my hands are I just saw it but I I
mean I didn't know anyone has changed
get a quarter of somebody
oh now I have the right let the record
Shot that this is a dime way smaller
than a quarter yeah
now I'm gonna grab this from your hand
okay
[ __ ] try and have me not do it okay for
real yeah
and just like that I put it behind his
ear open your hand what the [ __ ] man it
just disappeared though where'd it go
that's the thing when we're focused on
where things go we don't appreciate
Where We Are
now this dog killed a lot of sheep
that's great but you know what the
headline should say with coyotes but
instead of saying dog kills coyotes and
we glorify murder we should say dog
saves yes and that's that's that's the
point that's the problem things aren't
what we things are what we say they are
instead of what they really are you know
who writes the history books [ __ ] the
conquerors winners yeah all right man
he's right though I know but you know
he's right he's right let's just get
back to the coyotes I'm getting so mad
about everything else just
a boner right now oh wow yeah you have a
boner right now what happens with
endorphins when I get excited about
somebody's hands I get super hard I get
super hard I apologize oh great irony
Pyrenees I've had a boner since you sat
down what uh this one's a crazy story
okay
if it loads it's a guy that basically
fell off of a cruise ship all right I
thought we talked about this guy you
know Eric Griffin talked about it you
probably watched his riffing with
Griffin or he brought it up on the goal
now do a show there oh every Tuesday at
night oh that's probably that yeah so
but he was found 20 hours bless you I
know you hate germs this guy's such a
badass let me see this one he fell off a
cruise ship so it's kind of like how did
he fall off a cruise he says he doesn't
remember but he said there was some
drinking going on it was a family party
probably taking a selfie this
[ __ ] and they they didn't find
him until when 20 hours later and that
but they knew he fell off yeah they
reported him missing and then luckily
just one of those you know what do you
call them the boats they carry all the
stuff in there too yeah no no they find
them by aircraft or they nope from a
boat they spotted him and then they
called in the coast man I've always said
it don't do cruises dude I'm so you have
said that a lot I'm so afraid of this
now did he did were there sharks
involved hold on he said luckily he only
felt one finned creature come by and
then he just had have a fend off
jellyfish could have been a mackerel and
then he well he saw like things floating
by like bamboo and he would eat it for
energy helps really yeah he ate bamboo
yep
and he has a very country accent too
let me see that I'd play a little bit
for you here
we probably won't play because the stick
come floating by look like bamboo so I
started eating on it all right that
goddamn bamboo I started eating on it oh
look at Trevor Noah do you wanna we
should pull up my clip with on The Daily
Show you were on the daily talking about
the show as we see it I would love to
hear a podcast
um
you know actually um there's a great one
if you pull up my Instagram it's
probably safer
um Rick Glassman
is that you right there that's chin and
Nick Davis who's the producer golden
hour fighting in chin one dude you guys
were actually fighting Jim blossom in
the face get ready you guys were really
hitting each other yeah well Nick hit me
so I had to hit him back Chan good
punching you know what I'll tell you
something as great as you are uh
musically I'm actually surprised at how
good of a chin music you know how to
sweep uh scroll on down a little bit
actually if you go to Reels that'll
maybe help okay man all right this is
important yeah I know this is simple
scroll down okay as we see it keep going
tell me when
it's coming up
keep going there it is
here
hold up any show thanks for having me
when people tell you about a show and
they go this show is going to be about
these people you you immediately think a
few things it doesn't matter who the
people are so they go like this is going
to be a black show this is going to be a
show about autism you go like oh what
does that mean and then you watch the
show and you go like the people in the
show just happen to be dealing with
autism it's a show it's a story
incidentally I thought our show was
going to be a black show until it came
out and it's funny that you bring that
up as an example but there's a a friend
of mine who is an ex-girlfriend
um your hair we're okay we have time for
this yeah go go go go go ahead if we
don't have time I'll just cut it out
he'll leave it
um Sierra take charge it doesn't matter
Daily Show this show yeah
that's fine Alpha so there's gonna be a
lot of comments oh Glassman came in he
steamrolled he just made everything his
own he's so funny and smart he should
take over for Brian no no no they're
gonna they're gonna hate because there's
a community of podcasters that are like
the Macho podcasts where a lot of the
people here Macho that the people that
watch they're really like [ __ ] Jew no
no I know a lot of them a lot of them a
lot of them oh he's on OCD he doesn't
care about anything but [ __ ] germs no
Jew [ __ ] no no no wait that's what your
fans are and they're not gonna like this
but there's gonna be some odd balls like
in Wednesday that watches and be like oh
they could relate to somebody who's a
little quirky no it was a little
different
own way we don't have anti-semitic fans
I don't think you have a fan base yeah
I've seen your merch no no we don't need
to choose but we'll let them watch
that's what your shirts say listen they
they
Hugo Boss I guess was inspired by or
started by I don't know if there was a
Nazi influence there I'd like to talk
about other people okay
all right
you want some more you wanna yeah we can
show you some more reels one more here
go back to my Instagram well no but I
like that Jen don't listen to him let me
get another [ __ ] he's got a lot of good
stuff you know you know it's a fun one
scrolling up
how great was Mark Norman oh he's
fantastic he gave me the nickname thick
I did not know that no you know you know
him and Sandler are boys now he's torn
with Sandler what yeah hey because he
was with Bert you going up
um no it doesn't matter people will go
find it there's so much good stuff out
here wait what do you guys talking about
uh jelly roll it for okay go ahead and
click it if you want to if you want to
see I'm a freestyle I'm a very good
freestyle rapper there was a jelly roll
concert you know jelly roll that I know
the the donut
uh wrapper
jelly roll in my pocket big stands in my
Dome can't stop rocking till I get home
we got the jelly got the jam got the big
ass cinnamon bun ain't nothing unless
you put it in the Benjamins holla at it
when you cook pack sit back drink a cup
of coffee dunk that dunk trap I feel
like let it last matter dance clip clap
with my big dick with a little tit come
Cushman jelly roll is that the same guy
possible okay
um
[Laughter]
I do want to show you one for real I
want to show you go up go up to my uh go
to posts
we're gonna have to scroll down for a
bit I want to show you another freestyle
very funny because I want people to know
that Ari oh yeah he's and by the way
free plug I know you guys get a lot of
money for this yeah Jew his special I
don't know if you watched it it's one of
the best specials I've ever seen yeah
great thing keep going it's a bit down
I'll tell you when yeah oh it's
fantastic it's unbelievable I heard I
heard it crushes but I'm you know you
along at a perfect time we're at the end
so I'm gonna use this opportunity oh
there's more Awards I won keep going on
there we go uh comedians who could
actually rap I want people to know that
I'm I am for real and not just like a
funny rapper I'm hardcore can rap too
everybody raps not everybody is like for
real that gifted go ahead
I was like take a full screen then
those other guys rap too you're not like
me
but actually this is a little intimate
so okay my daughter passed when she was
seven years old I cried I grieved I had
a bury her soul I thought damn this is
love and life and living and killing it
loving it silliness so I mask it inside
I bury hidden joke be nothing but fire
breaching the Earth preaching your birth
Lord Jesus Christ is taking the earth I
scorched I heard it when I heard it Lord
above a 39 I push it in Cleveland
I'm a factory that's that I'm a factory
Mastery back to the fact that I don't
think they thought you should wrap back
to me now I live in another version
[Music]
rappers
[Music]
together
comedy actor
actor
[Music]
come on now this is if you watch to take
your shoes off you would know the
production value
on your podcast
did you assume he's a rapper why tell me
the truth what was your judgment you see
two black guys she's obviously probably
Jewish one's a Wayne's brother correct
Wayne's brother yeah I mean I mean he's
a way he's one of the David Wayne Jr's
son yes oh but I because I don't know
yeah because when you refer to him as a
brother it's just a little confusing
Wayne brother yeah no you're making this
pretty um
racial I just need to make sure that
that people speak out against and I'm
just I'm just making sure that you guys
are cool yeah cool we are we are for
equal so I want you know what bothers me
and I like that you did this with Noah
Trevor Noah like every time it's like
it's hey guess guys it's just a TV show
and there happen to be autistic people
and they're people too I know dude
thanks a lot but you know let's
acknowledge are you are you talking are
you are you talking [ __ ] about Trevor no
I'm just are you trying not to get on
I'm going I'm going bad on our culture
that he was on
no matter what that's all it bothers me
[ __ ] off everybody
he's like I got the new iPods airpods
wow I had new iPods I ruined that joke
what is this nfts
um oh look at we're plugging taiso cards
I have uh we're making uh a shout out to
Scott Hepburn by the way Marvel
illustrator unbelievable and we're
making trading cards of previous guests
and we have nine new ones coming out
shortly wow but aren't those incredible
yes also even Marc Maron 17 you guys
think okay oh yeah well they're limited
edition yeah
some of them some of them already saying
you wouldn't make marks more expensive
than the others no
I'm a collector and what I've learned
about the collecting Community is as
much as a lot of people are trying to
make money and wanting to make money and
flip a profit the reason why it's so
loved and the reason why I love it so
much is because I enjoy the art of
collecting and why are we not allowing
people to get in because they can't
afford it or this is more expensive no
things are only valuable because the
community is so large let's get the
community big so when you leave here
Mike the head of thick boy is the
ultimate collector oh going to his
office cards everybody this guy's credit
card sports cards are what is it he
collects it all right
so Ian Herring is coloring it and and
Scott Hepburn there's his Instagram
Kenneth underscore Scott underscore
Hepburn look at that he's unbelievable
yeah that's insane isn't that isn't that
really cool yes
yeah he's he's fantastic jeez well
you're fantastic thank you so much thank
you for coming on Rick and thanks for
letting me plug stuff
um it's important uh just so people know
in case like if you want to make a cold
open uh dramatic actor rapper
award-winning doesn't matter yes that
doesn't matter super quick I'm not doing
that anymore very quick hands but the
things that I need people to know
dramatic actor rapper yeah basketball
player bowler good guy good guy Spencer
good guy and you know funny well you
know what and and I'll tell you I'll say
this about Rick last well I communicate
Well yeah if you step in any arena with
Rick lastman I'm gonna say this if you
step in any arena with Rick Glassman
no matter what it is whether it's
bowling fencing or fighting or comedy
if you want to play
he'll put his medicine on you can put
some medicine on you
and you got medicine
because sometimes people come in a
little sick
your doctor you know what I mean you put
you put your medicine on your Glassman
well you you you'll heal them up real
quick so they start learning how to
behave in a correct manner that's all
I'm trying to say and I want to I want
to thank you for setting us straight
because we came in here a little
loosey-goosey a little while and yeah
and you used your hands to discipline us
and and you've been doing that with your
fingers the whole time I sometimes think
there's a woman standing above me uh
bending down asking me to play with her
nipples
okay is that what it is sometimes
sometimes it's just a journey no because
also you're a president you're grounded
ground's your presence so thank you for
being grounded here I've learned if you
want a sure-fire way to make a woman
have an orgasm I don't know if we're out
of time you have one minute not enough
time damn it man next time I might need
90 seconds
take your 90 seconds
B Where Are You Gonna Be you're closing
out the year in Boston I'll be in Boston
Massachusetts can I headline for you I
would love you to headline could you
bring me another one let me headlight
for you okay
God that oh look I'm at Venice West
December 27th I thought that was January
27th I don't think it's December 27th
it's January 27th maybe it's December
27th oh wow wow
that's the first one up there that's a
couple days after that's going to be
tough two days after Christmas yeah
that's a tough one isn't it but you're
in uh laugh Boston Boston Massachusetts
December 29 years 30 31 San Diego
California might drop comedy January
five to seven Fort Wayne Indiana Summit
Comedy Club January 13 14. Daddy's on
the road except for February yeah wow
that's it all right kids uh dates for me
for 2023 they'll be up I think the only
thing we have up right now is uh Tampa
that's end of January get your tickets
at thick boy.com right now oh look at
this way more than Tampa ah but we're
doing a big announcement so those are
just
congratulations thank you are you going
to do a thing that The Rock does where
before there's the announcement you say
like hey y'all I can't tell you what it
is now but and you're basically hyping
up the announcement it's not just it
that but you got to do it within it oh
you all got a big announcement well no
on on social media I'll do that you'll
clip this here's what you do you look to
camera yes all right you're gonna go a
little tight and you're gonna and you're
gonna do eye energy and the way you get
people in these go what's up everybody
my name's Rick Glassman and I got
something super exciting to tell you
about now I can't you know like yeah now
I'm quiet you have to sing wait wait let
me see you try that because you can just
clip it here just get it out of the way
all right okay good
with that energy
what's up everybody Brendan Chopper have
a great announcement but you gotta wait
well that's good okay it's good well I
don't want to overstay my welcome so
thanks for having me Rick thanks so much
for your outfit thank you so much for
your attitude thank you so much for the
lessons we've learned enlightened us and
thank you for slapping me into into line
Thanks for beating Brian up and we'll
see Brian get your thumb show I don't no
promises I guess if you let's let the
fans decide let's let your your
jew-hating fans decide if you guys want
Brian to come on my podcast comment on
this Brian has a little penis and if you
think that Brian
um maybe shouldn't come on or at least
not yet say uh Brian Brian smells like
poo poo Burgers so again if you wanted
to come on comment Brian is a little
penis and if you think he shouldn't
Brian smells like poo poo Burgers you
guys that's fighter and the kid we're so
excited next week big announcement we're
finding out where else he is other than
Naples uh my name is Rick Glassman and
as always scootoo actually wait oh sorry
that's over we have questions for Rick I
just remember we already ended questions
we already ended it I'm sorry oh this
was so much fun no go ahead fan
questions you forgot aren't you almost I
still got it um all right so this is
from Tom the booker he picked all these
different questions from people so Tom
is asking a question yep oh no he's
picking he he put the thing out there
and he picked all the questions
all right so where can hold on where can
I get really good priced rugs these days
oh thanks for asking Bobby Hanlon Bobby
if you uh uh Marshall rug Gallery
actually if you want to pull up my site
we could buy some martial art gallery
merch uh we don't really have to do that
um but yeah Marshall right Gallery Bobby
thank you so much for being such no no
right Rick lastman.com
um Marshall rug Gallery yeah we got we
got hats we got baby onesies
um we got sweatshirts
scroll down a little bit there they are
so if you guys are looking oh here's the
thing though a lot of people that are
looking to buy rugs unfortunately
they're looking for like a kind of
transactional customer client
um relationship we don't actually I
don't want to like make our company look
bad but they don't have no customers
martial art gallery
only family
great thank you okay thank you for that
and one last one okay uh due to Rick's
unorthodox podcasting what was the first
what was the first two words
due to Rick's unorthodox podcasting
Style
what what guest has the best chemistry
with Rick on his show much love Ricky
Glass and also eat my butt from Nestle
Hustle
uh the best chemistry you and I have
good chemistry
I mean in no particular order and I
might be missing some but two that come
to mind
Morris and Adam Ray Adam Rose have you
ever had Adam on here oh yeah I love
Adam we've had him on Miss Adam we're
gonna have him on again he's great do
you think he'll do it
hey yes man [ __ ]
Santino I I playing with Santino the
best it's great uh feel on I feel like
you guys be good together one
I don't like to talk about other people
but I sent him an Instagram message a
few years ago much like Brian he was
unavailable so I stopped asking
you know a lot of people when I first
started because I'm
such a loser no no it's fine it's fine
it's fine you know what I'm fine with
that I'm I'm a little bit of a loser I
like collectible cards and I play the
piano and I can solve a Rubik's Cube in
under a minute and I'm a little bit of a
loser
and people say no to me all the time and
it's fine at least Theo said you know
he's not going to do it yeah you gave me
the run around you're like you could
have just said let me wait until your
podcast is super successful that's what
I I'm trying to say is that bad I don't
know but yeah I've just had so many so
many very famous popular people in my
podcast but
that's not the point the point is I love
doing it because every week I had to
connect to another person yeah and you
know during covid that was really hard
yes
I appreciate it and it's just really
nice to have an outlet where we get to
paid a little bit of money sure but we
get to connect to somebody every week
somebody who wants to be there yeah
somebody wants to be with you and isn't
superficial about it and no but and
we'll like be there you know no matter
what right right maybe Brian so many I
could tell horse jokes I got a lot again
if you want to see Brian on just comment
Brian has a little penis no we'll put a
fan it's a hammer it's a hammer [ __ ] say
hammercock
balls too
thank you guys so much for having me um